cet été la sphère jeffrey epstein
faisait la une de l'actualité aux états
unis l'histoire folle de ce magnat de la
finance américain âgé de 66 ans accusé
de trafic sexuel impliquant des mineurs
et qui avait fini par se suicider dans
sa cellule d'une prison de new york
aujourd'hui c'est l'un de ses proches
d'amis qui est dans le viseur de la
justice jean luc brunel est un français
influent agent de mannequins et
fondateur de deux entreprises karin
models et mc2 model management
il est soupçonné par la presse de
complicité dans l'affairé ben stein
selon certains il aurait servi de
rabatteur de jeunes filles à l'homme
d'affaires américain
s'il nie en bloc ces accusations
plusieurs médias ont fait état de sa
présence en afrique du sud ce qui
laissait supposer jusque là que l'agent
tentait d'échapper à la justice
une version qu'il conteste il dit se
tenir à disposition de la justice
mais ce qui met à mal la défense de jean
luc brunel ce sont trois ancien
mannequin qui ont travaillé pour lui et
qui sortent aujourd'hui du silence des
femmes entendues par la police et qui
dénonceraient le rôle de rabatteur
auxquels se seraient livrés l'homme
d'affaires français mais les faits en
question serait aujourd'hui prescrits
toutefois le nom de jean luc brunel
serait déjà apparu à plusieurs reprises
dans le dossier de la justice américaine
autour de la sphère une femme aurait
avoué avoir été contrainte d'avoir une
relation sexuelle avec lui quand
d'autres le désigne comme rabatteurs
pour jeffrey epstein des accusations qui
accentue un peu plus encore la
réputation très sulfureuse qui existe
autour du monde de la mode ce soir le
modèle international christine hart
ainsi que christophe lèguevaques avocat
de l'association femmes libres et
spécialiste de l'affairé ben stein en
france sont avec nous pour lever un peu
plus le voile sur les coulisses de cette
industrie alors abus sexuels le milieu
de la mode est il complice
je voulais remercier christine hart avec
nous à l'inra sur votre histoire
the stowers modèle n'est voltaire alors
vous avez compris ce qui veut dire ce
que les mannequins ont thèse exactement
et vous allez nous en parler ce soir
merci d'être là parce que vous allez
voir vous allez entendre des histoires
incroyables et il ya m christophe
leguevaques merci d'être brunel en
france et c'est vrai qu'on a envie
d'entendre vos témoignages ce soir alors
la question je vous pose ces abus
sexuels
le milieu de la mode est il complice
alors il ya cristina cordula qui est
avec nous ça tombait bien aujourd'hui on
voulait absolument que vous veniez
aujourd'hui parce que c'est vrai que
c'est un ancien modèle est toujours
modèle est également géraldine maillet
voilà cet ancien modèle donc vous allez
pouvoir également nous nous éclairer là
dessus on va d'abord vous résumer la
sphère eckstein rapidement pour ceux qui
ne la connaissent pas 6 juillet 2019
j'ai fait jeffrey epstein 66 ans
milliardaire américain a été arrêté aux
états unis
à son retour de france pour des
accusations de trafic sexuel
le 8 juillet le comparer devant un
tribunal fédéral à manhattan il aura
abusé de dizaines de mineurs
voilà certaines âgées de 14 ans ne
foutent les centaines de pages de
documents judiciaires sont rendus
publics on apprend que ben stein et est
proche de personnalités y compris des
présidents bill clinton et donald trump
10 août
jeffrey epstein est retrouvé mort pendu
avec un drap dans sa cellule de la
prison de manhattan où il attendait son
procès il risquait la prison à
perpétuité alors sachez que cette
histoire aux états unis c'est un
incroyable qu'on soit là ils saluent et
ça ne parle que de ça et c'est vrai que
dans le milieu de la mode
il y à certaines dérives par exemple
christine vous avez écrit donc où je ce
livre et vous raconter l'enfer de la
mode dans le but de protéger les filles
mineures qui se lance dans le métier de
mannequin alors vous avez été témoin d'
histoire complètement sordides comme en
grèce lieu des premiers book au festival
de cannes aussi
racontez-nous ce qui s'est passé en fait
pour moi c'est pas vraiment un enfer
parce que cette fille toutes les filles
qui commencent jeunes qui commencent
avec un désillusion et moi pour moment
témoigne mon livre c'est pour dénoncer
un peu plus lâche 2 les filles
lhc défi de convaincre 14 ans non il ya
tout il ya commensacq ans à 14 après ça
dépend des les marchés aussi mais je
pense que c'est une question de dash qui
sont de petites filles qui n'ont pas le
caractère la personnalité pour dire non
ils se trouvent dans des situations que
peut-être une femme peut gérer ma qu'une
petite fille depuis l'adolescence alors
alors ils savent pas dire non alors dans
des situations que peut-être une femme
c'est clairement c'est quoi les
situations parce que vous dites par
exemple les filles sont parfois utilisés
comme une monnaie d'échangé sexuel
les jeunes filles sont manipulés et
perçus comme des objets elles sont
maquillées comme des femmes et sont
parfois âgés de 13 ou 14 ans et vous
dites il ya un exemple incroyable que
vous donnez vous dites que votre agence
de mannequins vous envoyer avec 10 fit
officiellement pour défiler dans une
ambassade en libye et là qu'est ce qui
se passe
oui nous on n'était pas un musée mais on
n'était pas au courant de la situation
et il s'en fiche
et c'est vrai que l'avion a atterri au
milieu du désert n'ont été le désert on
atterrit au mieux de décès on était dans
un bain coeur heureusement rien s'est
passé mais on pourrait être violée on
pourrait être 22 rien s'est passé mais
la question c'est que moi j'écris cette
nuit passée parce que je trouve que
quand j'aurai tournée de cette situation
que je vais passer la peur de ma vie
personne aucune fille a dénoncé à
lagence parce qu'ils avaient peur de
perdre plus avoir de travail ils ont
continué à faire ça à travailler à
travailler avec cette agence
moi je suis parti pour moi c'était un
acceptable c'était pas possible de créer
une agence nous envoient sans savoir
dire manicamp dans le désert sans savoir
qu'on était en banker pour défiler pour
kadhafi alors m christophe leguevaques
vous êtes avocat de l'association femmes
libres spécialiste de l'affairé ben
stein et donc brunel en france
l'association que vous représentez
espère que les victimes au sortir du
silence qu'elle dise pas ce que vous
dites si les victimes ne parlent pas
aujourd'hui c'est qu'elles ont été
vendus par leurs familles qu'elles ont
peur qu est ce que ça veut dire pour
vous devez corriger ce courrier tout à
l'heure maintiendront nous remonte à
il est beaucoup plus récente que 90 oui
c'est important en droit de se dire que
ce n'est pas prescrit c'est ça une
enquête peu poursuit
deuxième chose vous avez dit alors que
monsieur e
était soupçonné en fait il n'est pas
soupçonné il est accusé par plusieurs
personnes d'avoir commis des actes qui
ça qui ressemble à de la traite d'êtres
humains
alors il n'a pas été encore condamnés
dans minute accusés oui et ce qui est
important c'est que la qualification des
faits va permettre d'aller beaucoup plus
loin que ce qu'a fait le parquet jusqu'à
présent pour le moment on est souvent
juste une affaire de viol mais là nous
sommes en présence de traite de réseau
et d'organisations qui consiste à
fournir des jeunes filles mineures à des
adultes pour qu'ils puissent se disant
faire des massages mais c'est bien plus
que des massages puisqu'on a des
témoignages accablant sur la situation
de ces jeunes filles qu'est ce qui se
passe c'est qu'elles sont les
témoignages que les téléspectateurs
veulent savoir et mine de rien
aujourd'hui
c'est pour ça qu'on vous a fait venir
parce qu'il ya plein de jeunes filles
voilà qui veulent se lancer dans le
mannequinat et il faut les mettre en
garde aussi et c'est ce à quoi sert
votre livre qu'avant qu'est ce qui se
passe et il faut déjà mettre en garde
aussi les parents bien sûr ce que la
responsabilité de toute la chaîne est
importante
les parents font trop confiance aux
agences les agences sur les suivants les
agences
on a des comportements qui peuvent être
soit simplement négligent soit
complètement coupable et c'est toute
l'importance du dossier aujourd'hui
c'est de révéler le comportement des
agences syndicale est un point important
en droit c'est que pour être une agence
de mannequins il faut faire un dossier
il faut avoir un agrément et dans le cas
de retrait d'agrément il faut montrer
qu'on a une bonne moralité on dit on dit
aussi que ce sont les photographes
voilà qui sont aussi visés voilà parfois
et qui demande à des jeunes filles de
faire un peu n'importe quoi géraldine
maillet dit la vérité
et qu'est ce que vous pouvez dire vous
voilà pour les gens qui l'ont lu rien
d'abord brunel dans les années 90 quand
moi je suis mannequin il est patron de
l'agencé karine karine c'est une grosse
agence à paris avenue hoche
il ya estelle lefébure qui est qui dans
cette agence par exemple qui est un top
model à l'époque qui est juste une
énorme star il se vante d'avoir trouvé
sharon stone aussi donc c'est un truc
qui a pignon sur rue mais à côté de ça
il est très sulfureux dix records tout
le monde sait qu'on dès qu'on sort en
boîte de nuit aux bains douches au
palace brunel est là avec des dizaines
de nana plus jeune et plus jolies les
unes que les autres et on sait qu'il est
cocaïnomane
on sait qu'ils donnent de la cocaïne
aussi tout le monde le sait c'est un
secret de polichinelle mais tout le
monde le sait vous vous le savez oui je
le savais mais moi je l'avais je l'avais
croisé une ou deux fois j'étais allé
chez karine voulait pas de moi parce
qu'ils aimaient les blondes
voilà pour la barre après
comme jeffrey voilà donc moi j'étais pas
dans cette agence de mannequins mais on
la connaissait ont côtoyé les filles
mais s'était vu de l'extérieur comme ça
un sale type
après pour ce qui est du milieu de la
mode le milieu de la mode à des tests
les règles des tests est formaté et des
tests face un milieu qui est
transgressif
donc en fait lui n'arrête vous pouvez
dire par exemple d'un mois oui ok j'ai
des jolies filles autour de moi ils sont
jeunes
je peux vulgairement les baisers et
alors c'est pas un crime
voilà il ya beaucoup de cynisme dans la
mode et sauf que si c'est un crime bien
sûr sauf que la mode c'est toujours tu
quand il ya eu un reportage en 88 de six
billets ce qui justement pointé du doigt
les accusations de viol hydro ghelfi il
en a abusé sexuellement
on n'en a pas parlé à bouger silence
radio il ya eu un livre de michael gross
extraordinaire sur top model un sale
métier pareil on racontait tout sur
brunel personne n'a pas lent donc on a
là voilà pendant 7 à 8 miles sont
intéressés au monde de la mode
ils ont retrouvé un jeune mannequin qui
accuse son ex agent de viol et tentative
de viol regardez elle était tétanisé
regarder ça et des massages au visage
pour me décontracter et puis ça
descendait
des gestes va dire sur pattes long et
fès les jambes l'entrejambe et voilà ça
dérape et à ce moment là j'ai eu
plusieurs fois où effectivement ça aller
beaucoup plus loin et c'est et s'était
complètement voulu et qu'elle soit que
ce avait complètement qui s'il avait
capté en dessous non consentante devant
lui mais mais dans ces moments on est
complètement tétanisés et on peut rien
faire et si ils en profiter voilà alors
c'est bien un témoignage dans cet
habitat christina est ce que toi tu as
entendu parler de dérive comme on peut
l'entendre ce soir oui bien sûr j'ai
entendu parler la personne de karine
elle est ainsi elle est connue pour sage
c'est aussi l'avis de voir ces gars là
et c'est lui qui a fondé karine j'ai
entendu parler et les problèmes c'est ce
qu'elle a dit la jeune fils c'est c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment ce espace parce
que les filles et elles elles ont peur
de dire non elles sont encore trop
jeunes dans leur tête
moi ça m'a pas arriver ça parce que
j'avais déjà un grand galet donc je ne
sais pas les gens venaient m'approcher
mais je sais qui et qui arrive ça très
souvent dans ces très jeunes mannequins
non pardon tout a commencé tout je
connaissais que je connais je commençais
jeune mais quand je suis venu en france
j'avais 21 ans
donc j'avais déjà jaser de caractère et
je savais mais me protéger janka
là où christina a raison c'est qu'en
fait ils s'attaquent pas aux filles qui
bossent naco dire que brunel il était
irréprochable avec les top models de son
agence il était gentleman les gens
adoraient sortir avec lui en revanche
les jeunes filles qui arrivent après la
chute du mur de berlin il ya plein de
jeunes qui du bloc de l'est ce genre
d'arrivée hélas étaient de la chair à
canon d'ailleurs si des esclaves
sexuelles émissaire lead rabatteurs
quasiment un proxo en fait je vais dire
pour pour fournir des nanas pour des
soirées pour des boîtes de nuit pour des
soirées à cannes pour des soirées à
saint tropez et c'est ça le problème en
fait donc les filles qui bosse elle ne
risque rien mais les filles qui rêvent
de faire carrière et qui ne bossent pas
alors là forcément c'est des proies
idéales
alors on va remontrer un autre extrait
c'est l'agent de cette jeune mannequin
convient de voir qu'ils avaient
complètement pris le contrôle de sa vie
heureusement une photographe a remarqué
la détresse de la jeune femme et a pu
intervenir regarde
je les ai vus donc allongée sur le lit
elle est très mal au ventre je suis
demandé jeudi écoute qu'est-ce qui va
pas quoi pourquoi été comme ça qu'elle
veut un qu'est ce qu'il ya et donc là
elle m'avoue qui a la plus sa carte
bleue qui lui a pris donc sa carte bleue
ce téléphone qu'elle n'a plus droit de
sortir qu'elle n'a pas le droit d'avoir
de petits chéris que voilà elle peut pas
bouger de la maison donc la demo ya
problème la fin ça m'interpelle qu'en
rentrant je discute je dis aux gens
qu'il y avait dans la voiture c'est
quand même bizarre qu'elle est mal au
ventre comme sa fin c'est très dur quand
même ce qui lui fait lice on peut pas
laisser faire et donc de là une fille à
une des mannequins hommes et 10 mai à
temps c'est pas le pire puis comment ça
c'est pas le pire bah en fait ils
couchent avec ses mannequins couche avec
ses mannequins
voilà ça c'est vraiment un document pour
sept à huit live c'était très très bien
fait il y avait de très beaux
témoignages et c'est vrai que ça c'est
important pour que les parents voient ça
c'est ce que disait m il ya un instant
louis mathieu n'en sortent que pour une
question les parents effectivement mes
deux parents comment peuvent-ils être
informés c'est à dire que quand on est
pas du milieu
et quand tout d'un coup on s'intéresse à
votre jeune fils est arrivé une fois par
une de mes cousines 14 15 ans qui est
magnifique
comment savoir si on va avoir affaire à
une agence qui justement et de ce type
là où on note et que ça quand on est ce
qu a ôté par ménage ans déjà on n'a pas
besoin d'être de payer pour être dans
une agence de mannequin ne sera pas
besoin de payer pour faire un casting on
n'a pas besoin de payer pour constituer
un book temps d'allumer photos de
portfolio la mersey sanaa mais sauf à
vos raquettes les gens c'est à dire
qu'on leur fait croire on a tout et
n'importe quoi vas-y fois qu'on est
dedans
et oui cette agence ont été très
demandées préconise pour négligence et
il ya quand même des agences quand
pignon sur rue malheureusement j'ai
trouvé que ça dérape et quand les
agences de mannequins ont commencé à
être tenus par des hommes
voilà il ya eu un avant et un après
avancée des femmes qui sont occupés ça
se passait mieux
bah ça se passait quand j'irai nous
avons eu un scandale et l'inique la
banlieue de conakry toxiques et une
grande agence qui est très célèbre aussi
donc malgré tout dans les grandes
agences qui ont pignon sur rue ça dérape
maintenant mais c'est clair bien sûr le
dossier patine la principale maire
ghislaine durel sinon la principale
manière maquerelle c'est madame maxwell
la cnil gère les filles qui les forme
qui leur fait peur et qui leur les
éduque auquel puisse satisfaire les
ce prédateur le moko n'a pas dit c'est
qu'il ya une emprise une emprise
psychologique est fait par ces personnes
qui vont d'abord subjugué par l'argent
par la gloire et après vont prendre le
contrôle émotionnel de ces jeunes filles
encore une fois on parle de deux jeunes
filles de moins de 15 ans ça et donc
elles n'ont pas été forcément éduquer
n'ont pas reculé
les protections nécessaires elles sont
emportés par la part le flux par le flux
est donc elle se laisse faire on a fait
en fait à des vampires qui vont aspirer
à la fois leur énergie vitale de jeunes
filles et leur naïveté d'accord est-ce
que vous avez quelque chose à ajouter
christie et c'est ça moi je commençais
très tard je vais étudier mais c'est je
fais mes études j'étais très relax je
vais pas la désespère à sion d'arriver
au paris v surtout cette petite fille
ils sont très jeunes ils savent que
avant cinq ans la carrière est morte et
son de grammaire et ils sont désespérés
ils savent pas dire non
ils sont ici sont pris dans les
situations et il continue à accepter à
dire oui oui oui en pensant que
peut-être comme ça ça va marcher mais
j'ai toujours pensé comme qui avait une
omerta dans le milieu de la mode
alors d'abord le cas avec les filles
anorexiques on dit mais non pas du tout
elle ment est ce que vous vous au bts
que vous avez été victime de quelque
chose qu'on des cibles oui forcément les
des bloqueurs qui intimide il ya des
vagues dans votre avis un timide mais
sauf que moi je disais non j'étais il en
met plein timide comment ça se passe
pour nos téléspectateurs avec nous
encore parce que soit on est à le boulot
enfin soit en couches soit on couche pas
et on n'a pas le boulot adacore n'avait
pas le boulot mais je savais dire non je
j'étais en situation de force parce que
j'étais peut-être pas aussi dans la rue
je n'avais pas une pré car j'avais je
vivais chez ma maman
donc pour toutes ces raisons c'est plus
facile de dire non je ne stigmatise pas
et je ne condamne pas les jeunes filles
qui disent oui c'est très difficile mais
la mode est hypocrite
la mode est une sorte de nébuleuse kate
moss à 17 ans elle explose mais tout le
monde n'a pas la chance d'être kate moss
et pourtant elle a 17 ans voilà le monde
rêve de devenir quatre mois ci sur un
bindi qu'il ya dans la presse vient d
ici à des enquêtes qui ont été initiés
savent que ça touche tout le monde
milieu et ya des gens tellement puissant
qu'il ya beaucoup d' enquêtes qui sont
arrêtés en route je sais que les gens
vont faire partie
on va voir ce qu'elle pense de
téléspectateurs la monétique oui oui à
80% même en clamant à 17% christine hart
the stories modèle 9 heures tél voilà
c'est votre livre et merci m d'avoir été
avec lui
[Applaudissements]